[Music]
i'm a huge fan of the show uh and uh as
just about everybody is uh and i'm also
a very flattered you you your wife uh
came today she's backstage my wife's a
big fan of the show uh wouldn't wouldn't
miss it for the world she had to come oh
that's very nice yeah she she seemed
enthusiastic to be here uh is she you
said she's a fan of this show is she a
huge walking dead fan of the walking
dead show uh you know it's kind of
strange she's not that big of a fan uh
she's my wife i love her we'll be
married for a hundred years but uh you
know she never read the comics can't
stand the comics uh often tell me that's
what you do that's your life's work and
your wife's like ah not so much she's
like you know this helps me buy
groceries but other than that not so
much wow but she said but she likes this
show and that's the important thing
so you win i win again i win uh okay
nothing short of zombie mania in this
country uh walking dead uh as i said
congratulations are in order hugely
successful and it just seems to grow and
grow and grow
there are walking dead paraphernalia uh
all over the place
lunch boxes what else can you get lots
of stuff there's we got t-shirts we got
lunch boxes uh there's action figures
video games so there are kids
opening lunch boxes at school that have
decaying dead faces on them i'm not
gonna it's a little strange it's a
little strange but they seem to enjoy it
so who am i to deny them i'll walk into
a lunchbox yeah
there's also uh what have you turned
down there must have been people that
have approached you with a product that
they want to put walking dead on and you
said you know what that crosses a line i
can't do it i like to say i'm a sellout
but i'm not a total sellout yeah i've
been pitched perfume walking dead
perfume that was something that i said
smell like the undead yeah why why would
someone want that you're either going to
smell like a dead body or a sweaty
survivor which doesn't sound good to me
either way so uh yeah i was like no
thanks on that and then uh walking did
energy drink that was another big one
i don't know they've never seen a zombie
yeah i know that's not the way you'll be
walking like a zombie in no time
i'm not gonna drink this um there's an
app that's called uh dead yourself where
you can and it's becoming extremely
popular you can take a picture of
yourself and turn yourself into a zombie
and i did it earlier today with shocking
results
it's actually yeah that's me early in
the day that's
that was me before the app go back to it
look the hatchet cannot get through your
hair
look at that
i'm a zombie that can't be killed yeah
you can't get to my brain or your hair
helmet through this muffin on my head
you would be the most dangerous zombie
why is that because the brain you get
brain is protected yeah it's like you're
wearing a helmet